file but uh black is relatively active
got a lot of control over the center and
um this is interesting to me because i
remember studying this exact position
and magnus and his seconds have a lot of
experience here i remember nils
grandelius a swedish player had explored
this type of position with white
some very strong grand masters this last
night move for black maybe not the most
critical if i remember correctly black
hat did have the option
to be a bit greedy a bit more ambitious
but hans clearly just wants to grip and
survive
this opening and just to show one or two
points uh before we talk about more
about body language and the psychology
here but um if we just retreat uh if we
kind of
roll back just three or four moves
magnus here with white in a very
standard position did jump in with a
night check and this does look like a
sacrifice this check but if the knight
is captured by the black pawn then this
is a discover check discovered attack
against the black king and when the king
moves or the check is blocked white will
regain the peace with interest by
capturing this bishop so this check was
actually